here's the question for the audience out
there
want feedback on this story i want the
feedback i want you to tell me in the
comments david's gonna be watching him
what you would do in this situation what
would you do if you found a large
pile of cash and no one was around
to see what you were doing what would
you do if you found a hundred grand on
the floor in a bag and no one was around
no one was around let me tell you this
story and you tell me what we do so
this teen
let's get his name jose romanis he's a
19 year old
criminal justice student college student
in new mexico the dude finds a hundred
and thirty-five grand he's a criminal
justice student exactly
so jose our good friend jose that we're
gonna be talking about right now he's at
the atm like we've all used the atm
before he looks to his right and he sees
a bag of money just sitting there next
to the machine how much money was in
this bag a hundred and thirty-five
thousand dollars
okay
now again i asked at the beginning of
this segment yeah what would you do in
this situation so what's the first thing
you do
first thing you do is probably look
around yeah you look around you're like
who the hell's around here what the hell
is going on here
then what
what do you do then you inspect the bag
you inspect the bag you pick it up
you see a lot of money in there you
don't start counting it right now no you
just say blocks of money if it's that
bag right there it's
yeah you just you go dude there's the
bag
you know how they say secure the bag
homie secured the bag so what did he do
next and i want to find out what you
guys would do next what did he do
he called the po-po
called the police
i got a bag
of a lot of money here the police said
we're on our way
so the bag was accidentally apparently
left by an atm worker who forgot to fill
the machine probably was high
definitely was high or or had much
bigger
plans like we're still the rest of the
money this guy no this guy this guy left
the 135k and his buddy was going to come
pick it up and now this little 19 year
old yeah we ruined the ocean
yeah damn it freaking jose every time
oh 100 but you have it's always in a
group of two so that something like this
doesn't happen
look at the person
come on bro it's the cameras dude it's
just there's i'm so paranoid i'm like
there's no chance
i'm like there's no chance dude you're
always being watched there's just no
chance big brother's watching 100
percent there's always some sort of okay
so jose he called the cops would you
have called the cops uh what would you
have done you did i would have done it
you're calling 9-1-1 this is the problem
though i think we need to build there
needs to become there needs to be a
structure for this however much money
you find you get 10
because something needs to happen like
that to make it actually worth your
while yeah what happened to finders
keepers well
that was david i like that finders
keepers losers weepers what would you
have done david well here okay so i
would have been paranoid right
ah man the good paranoia though
i don't know i would have said uh i mean
obviously oh turn it into the cops but
it's like well someone left their bag
here well speaking of this
10
let's see what this guy got because he
called the police they obviously took
the money right they the police who
knows that the right thing
they go well yeah well done buddy
number one he got a round of applause
which does not pay the bills
exactly here's what he got
he was called a community hero by the
police
worthless by the way yeah he's got no
money there hey community hero all right
everyone break okay cool
the mayor and the police chief held a
ceremony to officially thank him hey
buddy
thank you thanks all right done
thanks jose he's out
get this get this he got several gift
cards to local restaurants now that is
what i'm that's what i'm talking about
chipotle yeah and then get this talking
about big money he got a 500 scholarship
500 500 scholarship to school that's
that's not 5 000. no that's offensive
it's like at that point just don't give
don't give me anything okay
and then here's the here's the here's
the kicker an itunes gift card yeah
season tickets to the university of new
mexico football games
with a bunch of sports paraphernalia
dude that's not bad dude what is it is
it paraphernalia or memorabilia because
paraphernalia sounds like an illegal
thing
memorabilia sports gear remember yes
yeah okay not bad if you're going if
you're getting alabama season tickets
right
university of miami or michigan
new mexico season tickets they're not
even a ranked team that's where he lives
dude i got that part that's where he
goes to school that's like giving me
season tickets to see fiu i i'm good i'm
good bro so now i gotta waste every
saturday in my life now because i found
money what am i gonna do with this
anyway right so
marcelo actually is not only our
in-house
comedian
writer joke teller he is our legal
expert i said what are the legal
ramifications on this he said i'm on it
sauce
here's what he found out he says yes
obviously you know it's not 135 grand
but it is better than you know going to
jail after all he is a criminal justice
major
and marcelo found this quote unquote if
you find a significant amount of money
check your local laws or contact an
attorney or the police if a law requires
that you turn over money you have found
to the police and you do not do so you
could be charged with larceny or theft
and it has to well each state has their
minimum they're like their minimum so if
it's over it's usually between 500 and a
thousand dollars so if you find
anything more than that in most states
you have to tell somebody or you go to
jail because this is my mentor go to
jail right yeah yeah because really
quick real quick just so we get some
feedback and we can keep talking if you
keep the money
you're keeping the money give a thumbs
up i want to see some thumbs up if you
said no i don't like this karma right
this ain't for me
they said and what i'm trying to do
thumbs down you're not keeping the money
we're going to be checking the comments
on that it's not just the money it's 135
420 cafe with bro joe commented lesson
keep the money keep the money i got to
tell you you went up the money save that
money but okay so him he would have
grabbed the bag of money okay
let's let's back up let's just talk
about jose and let's talk about
ourselves here okay so we're all clear
here
so there's jose
he's staring at the money
what do i do the police are about to
show up now i got five minutes of this
show i'm 19. i'm 19. i got the rest of
my life he says
you know how they say wwjd
what would jesus do
he thought
ww my parents do he thought about his
parents this is like a good
young hispanic male 100
good grooming he says quote unquote my
parents always taught me to work for my
own stolen money would never last steal
anything anytime i agree i agree i'm
with his parents so here is a situation
where david mann the thumbs up thumb
down one second here's a situation where
me i've got some money a hundred grand
isn't gonna change my life to the point
where i'm living a whole new life
however
hundred grand
angel on my shoulder saying yeah do
something good help people make sure
this money goes to its rightful owner
maybe it goes to a philanthropic
endeavor
then the devil
that's [ __ ] party bro 100 grand let's
do it we're going to buy this you're
going to go out you're going to have a
party
you get you know i think all of us
are dealing with the angel and devil
nobody says 100 of them we have a lot of
thumbs up on the channel
a lot of thumbs up man
thumbs up if you're keeping the money
your thumbs down if you're turning it
into something why don't you take that
money and put it straight into bitcoin
does anybody even know what happened
like is that just like the ultimate way
to get away with it that's a that's the
ultimate oh my god
but this is my my perspective is if i'm
his parents right i'm i'm this guy's
parents and we're immigrants
yeah i'm pissed there is nothing more
valuable than freedom
so this kid takes that 135k he runs away
with it and it's under his bed
next thing you know the whole family's
arrested for aiding in the bedding
now we worked all our life to get to
america and this kid just took it from
us because he couldn't keep his hands in
his pockets
wow spoken from a a latino man whose mom
escaped communists 100 involves freedom
100 good business i am i am speaking for
all those immigrant parents out there
that would say the same thing call the
police because you get caught for that
money
well hold on
your family half cube and half dominican
right 24 years old right david yeah 25
years old 100
colombia colombian immigrant family
correct you're keeping the money i agree
with you
keeping the money what'd you do with the
money i listen uh marcelo has a point my
my mommy would say yes she would should
be
should you return the money um you know
that money that you're not stealing
anything you're not taking anyone's
money from their house that money is
insured i worked at a bank
sure good point here this is where we
have our local bank teller david
house we got robbed that's why i think
that's what they tell you when you're
it's called the fdic yeah you're getting
robbed like give them everything that
money's insured okay yes bro you left
the bag out that's your problem anyway
this is
my solution
this guy's laughing so hard i think we
should go
thumbs up or thumbs down jorge you're
keeping the money you're calling the
cops
anyway you guys are going to jail bro
i'll bail you out here's the lesson here
you know
it's it's not not everything's black and
white you find 135 grand some things are
latino okay
some things are brown yes so
uh good deeds can go viral
you can just get gypped
this guy got a round of applause and
some season thinking mexico lobos
football and he got featured on the
sauce i mean seriously this guy got
nothing for this this guy he's oh he's
man poor kid he had 135 kidney benefits
if i'm freaking new mexico university i
want to promote this story as much as
possible these the kind of students we
have here i give a little kid a
scholarship papers they did it's five
hundred dollars
okay here's a 500 scholarship go [ __ ]
there's a 500
say if you end up hearing this we'd love
to speak with you jose romanis
19 year old criminal justice student out
of new mexico
half our audience thinks that you're a
freaking loser bro half our audience
respects you so
poor kid poor kid
no man no not poor kid
not poor kid at all dude he could have
invested into bitcoin
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauz cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken